we've all seen the the  what's what's going on in the world at  the moment with ukraine and nobody's  happy with what's going nobody should  ever accept any any killings in the  world any oppression uh  but uh we've all we've never been uh  allowed to speak about politics in  sports but all of a sudden now it's  allowed so that we're allowed i hope  that people also uh look at the  oppression everywhere in the world i  mean the palestinians have been going  through that for the past 74 years and  and  i guess but i guess because it doesn't  fit the narrative of the  of the media of the west uh we couldn't  uh talk about it but now that so we can  talk about the ukraine we can talk about  palestinians so please keep that in mind  thank you very much  you